there are singles signals tonight that
what administration officials
characterized as an immediate threat by
Iran against American interests in the
Middle East has diminished as of now
today lawmakers receive briefings from
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo acting
defense secretary Patrick Shanahan and
Joint Chiefs chairman general Joe
Dunford national security correspondent
Jennifer Griffin reports tonight from
the Pentagon it was not very
enlightening Democrats who demanded
national security briefings in the wake
of escalating tensions with Iran
remained skeptical that the
administration had a plan to avoid a war
we know Iran is bad okay what is the
policy going forward we there wasn't
enough information on that a war with
Iran would be an absolute disaster and I
hope the American people tell this
administration that we will not go to
war this is blind escalation with the
hope that the Iranians will come to the
table in the end Republican lawmakers
had a different reaction it was a very
good briefing they explained to us how
the Iranian threat streams were
different than in the past that the
attack on the ships and the pipeline was
coordinated and directed by the Iranian
there is no intention to go to war in
the region this is mated this is a
deterrent operation to stop Iran's
escalation acting defense secretary
Patrick Shanahan defended the
intelligence that led the Pentagon to
deploy the USS Abraham Lincoln ahead of
schedule that intelligence is borne out
in attacks and I would say it's also
deterred attacks we have deterred
attacks based on our reef posturing of
assets the turret attacks against
American forces we walked through our
efforts and our ultimate objective over
the past days which has been to deter
Iraq iran's Foreign Minister ruled out
negotiating with the Trump
administration warning third parties may
try to pull Iran and the u.s. into a
direct confrontation we believe that the
United States is playing a very very
dangerous game general Joe Dunford the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs has
canceled a trip to NATO
due to quote unforeseen commit
mints that require him to remain in
Washington DC a sign that tensions
remain Brett Jennifer Griffin at the
Pentagon Jennifer thank you